sometimes you like to scare you like
during my grandmother's funeral like the
priest goes like this he looked at all
of us in the pews and he goes uh Dorothy
has been preparing for this moment for
decades decades yeah decades she's been
preparing for her soul to ascend for
decades and then everyone's like
shifting in their seats looking at each
other like oh God we're all heathens
we're all gonna die I was at a funeral
just recently how'd he die uh that guy
choked on a pork chop no I swear yeah
yeah I swear on everything yeah no this
is sad because this is column I swear to
God
wait a minute yeah something happened
where he choked on a pork chop and then
Lexie you know he fainted and then they
couldn't get him out of it he had brain
damage and then it was like it's over
you know Jay has been prepared for this
moment for decades
he's been preparing to choke on a pork
chop and hit his head when it's your
time it's your time